-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now if you don't mind, we're
going to get to the news.
The White House announced over
the weekend that a third batch
of classified documents
was found
at President Biden's
Delaware home.
You know, finding new ones
every few days isn't helping.
What are you guys
doing over there?
Searching one drawer at a time?
Did he hide the documents
in an advent calendar?
[ Audience laughs ]
That's right, a third batch of
classified documents was found
at President Biden's
Delaware home
in a room next
to his garage.
Man, is there a more Biden
hiding place than the room
next to the garage?
Just telling neighbors, "Yeah,
sure, you can borrow
the weed whacker. It's in
the room next to the garage."
If you hit the nuclear codes,
you've gone too far.
[ Audience laughs ]
President Biden visited Ebenezer
Baptist church in Atlanta
yesterday to honor
Martin Luther King Jr..
Became the first sitting
President to deliver
a Sunday sermon.
And I'll tell you what,
when he was done,
there was not an open eye
in the house.
[ Audience laughs ]
After the FAA last week
temporarily grounded
all domestic flight departures
due to a computer outage,
it's been reported
that the software responsible
is years away from
a potential update.
Really? Because I feel like if
you just put Apple in charge,
they'll update it
every three months.
[ Audience laughs ]
New York mayor Eric Adams
yesterday visited El Paso,
Texas, to tour immigration
facilities and meet
with local officials.
Dude, you're the mayor
of New York.
Why are you wandering all over
the country like a dad at Sears?
"I'm going to go look
at the tires."
"Dad, we're here
for my school supplies."
[ Audience laughs ]
Lottery officials have announced
that the Mega Millions
$1.35 billion jackpot was won by
a single ticket holder in Maine.
And if you're wondering what
they're going to buy with that,
Maine.
[ Audience laughs ]
The national weather service has
warned that a recent drop
in temperatures in Florida could
cause iguanas to enter
a dormant state and fall out of
trees, which has left residents
of Florida scrambling
for recipes.
[ Audience laughs ]
"Mom, what's in the pasta?"
The Dallas Zoo was closed
on Friday
until a 4-year-old
clouded leopard named Nova
was returned to her habitat.
Oh, you mean the jungle?
[ Audience laughs ]
News flash -- no leopard's
habitat is Dallas.
Leopard print, sure,
but not leopard.
[ Audience laughs ]
And finally,
Italy's most wanted man,
an alleged organized crime boss,
Matteo Messina Denaro,
was arrested today
after 30 years on the run.
He's expected to serve
at least two life sentences,
plus five years consulting
on an HBO series
about his life.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.